hey I'm Amory I'm here at BuzzFeed and
I'm gonna be talking about my first
which is scary first song you write I
think it was a song called voice six
like the first proper song I wrote and
it was about six boyfriends that I'd had
and just mucking all of them off because
they were all horrible so I actually
like that something maybe I'll bring
that out one day change its a boy
severly first thing you do when you're
back in England I'll go shopping for
food because I need a full fridge of
fresh food when I'm back when I'm when
I'm away in other countries and I'm
staying in a hotel it really stresses me
out that I can't just open a fridge and
there's just food whenever I want it's a
if I wake up at 3 a.m. and I want a baby
Bell they're not there so yeah I need I
need to go shop food shopping first time
you were recognized in public I feel
like I really am bad at even noticing
things like this because I just try and
I'm so anxious that I just walk around
with my [ __ ] horrible this one time
when I was in Germany and it was
freezing so I had an excuse of like
wearing a big hoodie and and a scarf
like covering my face and I was just
walking around my friends and I
literally only had my nose out I swear I
had got his honor my noses out and a
girl came up to me said EU Amory and I
was like how the did you know that from
my nose so yeah that freak yeah
first aleb crush I think it's gotta be
Eminem or Nelly
they were my my favorite I had a lot of
crushes christina aguillera weirdly I
have never met any of them first
cellphone I don't know if you had this
hair based like a 3310 a Nokia 3310 and
I had to snake on it and I just would
play that every day first singer or
musical act you'd want to collaborate
with I think the first person I really
really loved growing up was around this
and she always comes from a really
strong point of view on whatever she's
been through feel like she's been
heartbroken but she always ends up being
a stronger person out at the end of it
and that's what she inspired me to do so
we just write like the strongest jump
remember in the whole world first
embarrassing on the stage moment there's
been a few the first major one was
probably when I was I was actually
performing in New York I was doing a
duet with this guy called will hurt and
he does crazy dance moves he's crazy and
he's flinging his arms around and I was
I had the mic to my mouth and he smashed
the mic into my mouth and my tooth cut
in half and I had it in my mouth on
stage and I ran off spit it out come
back and finish the vomit that was the
first one another one was when I had
tried not to wear skirts on stage
because it's really hard and I jump
around a lot but this particular time I
was wearing that big knickers I thought
I'll be fine and I sat at the edge of
the stage for this moment in the set and
as I turned around the skirt flew up and
the knickers had moved right up my ass
and someone filmed me turning around and
there's a picture laughs on the internet
so kind of a Google first time you met
lau was in london actually and we met
when we were doing like a radio show
thing and he was so chill and i was so
hyper and he was lovely and then we had
the song and now i love you he's one of
my favorite people first musical
inspiration honestly I think it has to
be someone like Eminem because when I
was a teenager listening to him but when
I was a kid I totally was so shocked at
how he just didn't care and how I just
said anything whoever it made people
feel uncomfortable whoever if he was
talking about like real serious issues
in the world or anything like that and
it really just inspired me to just
always go beyond that little barrier of
like safe lyrics or anything like that
so
here's an inspire my first job actually
was teaching crying yeah I'm a black
belt in Shotokan this was when I was
maybe like 16 or 17 and I got a diploma
in teaching karate and I talked it all
beginnings and it was the best ever and
then I've got an actual job like a
boring shop job and I got fired from
that night in a week and I've got
another job when I got fired from that
in a week and that's what I do music I
was fired because I have my phone in the
in the stockroom and that's lit and they
were like we're gonna have to look for
your phone to see if you've been
stealing anything I was like you're not
looking for my phone they were like
we're even looking for your phone on
your fire don't wait to see yeah but I
wasn't feeling anything but I just do
want him to look through my first
celebrity who followed you on social
media probably ed Sheeran because we
were we were friends right from the
start and I remember having like 20
followers on Twitter and he tweeted out
saying everyone say hi to memory and
then I got like thousands of followers
like that sweet thanks mate my first pet
the goldfish count as pets
my daddy's have so many fish in this big
tank so that was kind of my first kind
of experience of a pet but also my first
proper pet was a rabbit and we called
her blossom and then I've got a number
of it called pal they're both dead now
first big date okay so I feel like I've
never been on a date before whenever
I've got with someone it's because we've
been friends before so I feel like it's
just naturally progressed into being
with someone and I've never really like
said she has this she knows that so I
don't I have still have yet to
experience my first big date guys first
big singing gig for people to come and
see me was in 2015 and it was a 300
capacity place in London and before that
I've been touring with with a group
called rudimental and I'd been doing
shows to thousands of people and big big
venues and
big big festivals but it was never for
my own music I was more scared that the
my first gig then I was at the thousands
of people so I loved it and I wore heels
and ended up taking them off and I said
bare feet on stage and it was disgusting
my first CD or album you ever bought
probably Alanis Morissette or Alicia
Keys or pink they're all around the same
time I think for me I was like Christina
Aguilera pink I love them all my first
kiss oh my first kiss was disgusting and
I didn't know how to do it so I don't
think about my song right now is called
birthday and if you can get suits about
being your birthday and yeah it's fun I
hope you like it goes into it
[Music]